hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
and today we're gonna be showing you
guys how to get all of the new skins and
the new headpiece for the characters of
borderlands 3 doing the mayor's quest
line these are some of those crew
challenges that we got in the main game
I think there's like three or four of
them this time around in the DLC also I
shouldn't have to say this but spoiler
warning ahead for all the enemies and
all that [ __ ] honestly if you didn't
want spoilers you really shouldn't have
clicked on this video to begin with yeah
and I just want to preface that every
one of the enemies you kill will give
you a skin for one of the vault hunters
so if you kill one of them and it
doesn't drop the one for your character
don't worry you just have to kill the
other remaining four or five and then
once you complete all of them you get
the headpiece for the specific ball
hunter that you've completed it with so
if you want to get all the characters
you have to complete this again for
every character so I'm only gonna be
showing most and she's the only
character I really play but you'll get
the gist as we go along yeah I'm gonna
shut up I'm gonna show you guys they'll
be timestamps and stuff in the
description if you want to go to a
specific spot but that like to be if you
do enter subscribe before new take care
let me know what you guys think about
the outfit and the headpiece in the
comments below peace out
[Music]
you